the post pre-sequel dlc parade marches
on this March with the announcement of
clap tastic voyage and ultimate vault
hunter upgrade pack - one of them is a
Borderlands II play on words that
references the 1966 sci-fi movie that
inspired the premise of this first
campaign add-on and the other one is
ultimate vault hunter upgrade pack 2
let's get that one out of the way first
basically all it does is raise the level
cap to 70 giving hunters 10 new levels
to gain and 10 new skill points to earn
for the first time in Borderlands
history it will now be possible to
unlock all three capstone skills from
different skill trees as a result of
this news Hyperion is projecting a 400
percent rise in respect revenue but
that's not enough for handsome jack
after rising to the top of the Hyperion
ranks he's out to increase his power and
money money and power minute after
minute hour after hour when he learns
about a secret cache of valuable
Hyperion code that's been hidden away in
claptraps brain he digitally shrinks you
down and sends you in there because
that's how you recover lost files in a
world with space travel and hoverbikes
and where do you go in the weird mind of
claptrap back to Firestone
well not like Firestone Firestone rather
these are claptraps memories of
Firestone the conceit of Clapp tastic
voyage makes basically any location in
series history fair game for revisiting
and you will revisit some familiar
places even though they may not look
super familiar what with all the tron
blocks lying around to remind you that
you are in a digital world so you can
visit with this cadaver in doctors Ed's
office again but you'll also be off to
new areas some of which will just be
digi blocked castles in the Virtua sky
not exactly an attractive landscape but
you don't have to linger there too long
before you hyper door your way out of
there familiar landscapes come with
familiar faces naturally and I saw
Patricia Tannis doctors ed and Lilith
along the way all hologram of fide and
acting kind of weird the way Holograms
do this is claptraps brain after all so
you know he's just miss remembering
stuff like crazy on top of these
figments you've also got handsome jack
and
traps consciousness providing their own
voiceover commentary so there's no
shortage of jibber-jabber
to entertain you in your travels and no
shortage of enemies mostly familiar
types but all corrupted and did you
fight so they look a little different
and die a little different you can also
shoot these volatile bits that hang out
in the sky and change color to
correspond to what kind of thing they
will spew out when you shoot them red is
good and green is bad because there are
no traffic laws anywhere in Borderlands
at all the whole glitchy theme extends
to weapons as well and though I didn't
get to wield one there are apparently
glitch versions of weapons that will
periodically do weird stuff like SMGs
that just start spewing explosive
shotgun shells weird but weird is the
order of the day for clap tastic voyage
the dlc that seems aimed at making
Borderlands more easter-egg II than ever
roll fine prints Coolio outro
[Music]